Hello, class of 2029.
My name is Justin
Popp, and I'm here
today to give you
a lecture on seizures
and epilepsy.
Dr. Randy Ramos
helped me create this
lecture, and I just want
to thank him for all
the help and guidance
along the way, as well
as him helping me
through my scholarly.
Here are our
emails if you
guys have any questions.
These are the
assessment objectives
for you to read
at your own time.
I'm not going to talk
about much of the
history here. This
is more background
information for
you to think about
and realize how far
we've come in terms
of society and the
stigma around seizures
as well as the
treatment of them.
This slide is also
here to show you that
all three of these
people are having
seizures, yet they look
physically different.
You see a little
child staring off
into space. You see
a man on the floor
posturing with his
arms extended, and you
see a man staring
off into space here.
And these are
different types of
seizures that
we'll get into, but
the point is
that seizures can
present in various
different ways.
And that is
because of the area
affected might
be different.
Area of the
brain might be
different
that's affected.
so a seizure is a
transient alteration in
cns sensory motor
autonomic and or cognitive
function due to
excessive and synchronous
abnormal neuronal
activity from a
population of cells
in the brain and that
could be in the
neocortex or the thalamus
for example this
excessive and synchronous
abnormal neuronal
activity leads to a
disruption in the
homeostatic balance between
excitation and
inhibition of neurons.
Important to note,
you can have seizures
but not have epilepsy,
but you cannot
have epilepsy without
seizures. We'll
get into a strict
definition later on.
Some causes of seizures
include head trauma,
acute metabolic
or electrolyte
changes,
medication, ******,
tumor, fever, especially
common in children,
hydrocephaly,
infection, etc. And the
seizures can be
focal, meaning it's
discreetly localized
to one hemisphere or
generalized. And that
means it's diffusely
distributed across
both hemispheres.
This vitamins
mnemonic can help you
remember some causes
of seizures. So
V, vascular event,
infection, trauma,
autoimmune,
metabolic ingestion,
or withdrawal of alcohol.
Neoplasm, you could have
psychiatric seizures
where you display
symptoms of a seizure,
but your EEG is
negative, and pregnancy,
and that's through
eclampsia, which you'll
learn about in your
reproductive slash OB-GYN
section of your medical
school education.
And these are also
some drugs, chemicals,
and compounds
that are known to
induce seizures,
and you could see
it's vast, so just
things to be aware
of when you get out
into into the clinic
and actually
practicing medicine.
So these are some
different terminologies
that you'll see here.
I'm not going to go over
all of them. I would
recommend you read these
on your own and also
watch the YouTube
video clips as it'll
help cement and help you
retain the information
and the categorization
of the seizure by
watching an actual person
unfortunately suffer
that type of seizure.
Some important
ones to note, you
have tonic seizures
where you see
a stiffening of
the limbs, whether
it's the back,
arms, and legs.
Anything that says
colonis or colonis or
clonic is repeated
jerking movements of
muscles on one or
both sides of the
body. It's like,
imagine like swatting a
fly repeatedly out of
your face. You could
have a tonic or drop
attack seizures.
And these patients
who suffer these may
need a helmet to
prevent head trauma.
You have your tonic
-clonic grand
mal seizures,
absence seizures,
where the person may
look like they're
staring off into space
and they'll go right
back to their regular
activity with no
postictal confusion.
You could have gelastic
seizures of both
with laughing and
giggling without other
convulsive seizures, as
well as you could have
digrastic seizures with
bouts of crying, or
emetic seizures followed
by bouts of nausea
and vomiting. And I
mentioned psychogenic
seizures earlier,
where a person may sort
of act like they're
having a seizure with
no neurological origin
and a negative EEG.
And this is
usually treated
with psychotherapy. be.
So more terms. The
term convulsion is old
and vague, and it was
used to denote a tonic
-clonic seizure, and
it may be used to
indicate a seizure
with a prominent motor
activity. Another term
you should know is
fortimatism, and this
is a repetitive motor
activity that are
coordinated and resemble
voluntary movement but
are not purposeful, such
as lip smacking,
chewing, swallowing. A
point I would like to
make here is this is
not tardive dyskinesia.
Tardive dyskinesia
happens when you give
D2 antagonizing drugs
to psychotic patients
such as haloperidol.
This D2 receptor
antagonism on the
cholinergic neurons
in the striatum of the
basal ganglia will
lead to aberrant and
excessive acetylcholine
release, which
causes the feature of
tardive dyskinesia.
Patients who are manic
or psychotic will
get these medications
like I described.
But what I want to
mention is that this
tardive dyskinesia may
look like an automatism
clinically. However,
the neuronal
path of physiology
underlying
these two conditions
is different.
You may also have
sensory or subjective
phenomena. If the seizure
is in the occipital
lobe. You might have
visual symptoms,
auditory symptoms if it's
in the temporal lobe.
Hallucinations
might also occur
with seizures in
the temporal lobe.
You may have
paresthesias,
sock-like sensations,
numbness, pain
if the seizure is
occurring in the
somatosensory cortex,
for example. And
you may also have
experiential phenomena
such as fear,
sadness, elation,
or feelings
of deja vu or jamie vu.
This slide is to
show you guys that
this is the classification
of seizures.
A point I'd like
to make is that
there is some old
terminology here.
I am not telling
you much about
the old terminology
because I'm not
trying to confuse
you. However,
I would like to
mention some of the old
terminology. So for
example, A focal aware
seizure was originally
called a simple
partial. So what I
have here is that the
simple is an old term
for consciousness
not being affected,
so the patient's
aware. So simple was
aware. Simple is now
aware. and you see
complex is referring to
impaired awareness
while partial is
referring to the focal
nature, meaning one
hemisphere of the
brain is only affected.
But we'll go through
all of these.
We'll go through
this categorization.
This new terminology
is the terminology
you need to know
for your exam.
So this diagram
is just for you to
understand how seizure
activity can spread
from one region of the
brain to the other.
So if we look at
this diagram here,
so what we see
is that you have
a seizure focal
region. Let's
say it's in the
cortex somewhere.
This seizure, this region
can send seizure signals,
hypersynchronous,
aberrant neuronal
activity. It may cross
the corpus callosum.
It may be going
through the internal
capsule. It may
cross the anterior
commissure to another
region of the brain.
And that is how
this signal spreads.
And you see dye is
injected here into one
part of the cortex.
It crosses midline
and then goes into
the other area of
the exact mirror
image of the opposite
side of the cortex
here. And you can
also see it goes
subcortically as well.
you might have
seizure activity that
starts somewhere else
in the cortex that
goes to the thalamus
and this then spreads
diffusely across a
lot of other brain
regions and it's
important to realize
these thalamocortical
pathways here are
vital in the pathology
of absinon seizures
and you can see that
here you have some
dye injected into
the thalamus and you
could see it spreading
into the cortex.
So let's start with
the categorization
and a little bit about
each of these
types of seizures.
So you have focal
aware seizures. These
were your simple
partial seizures and
focal means it originates
in one hemisphere
of the brain and it
can be generalized
if the seizure
activity crosses the
corpus callosum or
anterior commissure.
Automatisms are
common such such
as lip smacking
or blinking, and
important to note
that awareness
or mental status
is not impaired.
Vocal aware seizures
can have auras, which
are subjective
experiential phenomena,
such as alterations
of sensory
perception like
taste or smell, and
naturally these
manifestations
depend on the brain
region involved.
And another example
I'd like to give
here is that imagine
clonic movement
in the left upper
extremity of the
patient may indicate
right precentral
gyrus seizure
activity. And I like to
say, think of your
homunculus, right?
Next, you have focal
impaired awareness
seizures. These
are your complex
partial seizures,
where you have
complex meaning
altered mentation.
And it's naturally
characterized
by altered
awareness or mental
status during
the seizure.
And it may start very
subtly manifesting
with slight
confusion or slowing
of responses, and
the patient may
experience amnesia
after the event.
A point I'd like
to make is that
it's sometimes
difficult to
determine if awareness
was impaired.
For example,
you may be totally
conscious you might
have a focal aware
seizure, but not be able
to respond to verbal
stimuli because
of the seizure being
located in Broca's
area. So you may be
aware during the seizure,
but if the seizure
is occurring in
Broca's area, it may
look like you can't
respond to people
around you, and it might
seem that your
awareness is impaired.
The most common
location for these
seizures is the
temporal lobe,
specifically the oncus
and the hippocampus,
and this may
explain some of the
amnesia a person may
experience. And the
most common manifestation
is automatisms.
The most common motor
manifestation
is automatisms.
So I put this slide up
here to realize that
truly how a person
presents with their
seizure truly does
depend on what part of
your brain is actually
experiencing seizure
activity. So for
example, you have your
motor cortex and your
somatosensory cortex,
your central sulcus
dividing them. And if
you have seizure
activity on different
areas of the motor strip
or the somatosensory
cortex, you'll have
different symptoms.
Maybe if the seizure
activity is located
medially on the
motor cortex, you
might have leg
twitching, for example.
While a little
bit more laterally
on the motor
strip, you might
have grimacing,
for example.
If the seizure
is located in the
occipital lobe, you
might see scotomas,
flashes of light,
for example. It's in
the auditory cortex.
You might experience
ringing, hissing,
or other noises.
And another thing
to realize is that
frontal and temporal
lobe seizures may cause
autonomic dysfunction,
and frontal lobe
seizures can cause
personality and executive
function changes
during the seizure.
Moving on to
generalized tonic-clonic
seizures, the old
term, maybe some of you
have heard this, is
a grand mal seizure.
These seizures usually
do not have an aura,
such as a flash of
light, but it may be
preceded by a prodrome,
which is a vague sense
that a seizure will
occur. And this can
happen days before the
seizure occurs, and
this may include a
headache, mood changes,
sleep disturbances,
or even anxiety.
Seizure onset is
abrupt, most often with
loss of consciousness
and generalized
tonic contraction,
and it may be
initiated with a series
of myoclonic jerks.
And there's usually
three phases, a tonic,
colonic, and postictal
phase, which we have
described here. So
the tonic phase might
manifest its upward
eye deviation with your
eyes half open and
your mouth wide open as
well. There may be
involuntary movement
of the contraction of
your respiratory muscles,
and this produces a
forced expiration.
This is your
epileptic cry.
I would Google this and
try to listen to it.
It's quite scary. and
it'll also help you
remember sort of what
that sounds like and
might make you think
what a patient might be
feeling when they're
having this experience.
Cyanosis may occur
during the tonic stage
in association with
apnea and then the
tonic phase gradually
evolves to a clonic
activity and the clonic
activity is a series
of rhythmic jerks that
slowly decrease in
frequency over the
course of the seizure.
and during the postictal
phase the individual
is limp and unresponsive
so post meaning
after and ictal
refers to seizure so
this is just after the
seizure the patient
will be limp and
unresponsive respirations
may be loud and snoring
as the patient starts
to get control over
their masseter and
other jaw muscles please
remember your abcs
make sure the patient's
airway is patent
in the postictal
phase because, like I
said, they're starting
to regain control of
these muscles, and
they might not have a
patent airway, and that
would be very bad if
the airway of the
patient is not patent.
Tongue biting is
common, but it's not
necessarily a
reliable indicator if
someone had a seizure,
and the patient may
have incontinence
of urine or stool.
so this concept status
epilepticus is a
board's favorite it's
very clinically relevant
which is why we're
talking about it status
epilepticus is a
neurological emergency
that requires immediate
intervention and the
goal of the therapy
is to stop seizure
activity before neuronal
injury occurs and
this might be due to
excitotoxicity and
metabolic homeostasis
being altered like ******
time is tissue survival.
And the definition
is a seizure that lasts
more than a certain
number of minutes or
a series of seizures
in rapid succession
without full
neurological recovery in
the interrectal period.
Typically, status is
considered at five
minutes for convulsive
seizures and at
10 minutes for non
-convulsive seizures.
I leave it to Dr.
Goldstein to teach
you more about the
treatment of this,
but usually first
line is Ativan.
And another fact
I'd like to mention
is that most
cases of status
do not have a
history of epilepsy.
Moving on, focal
to bilateral
tonic-clonic seizures.
So a lot of generalized
seizures can start
as focal-aware or focal
-impaired awareness
seizures and progress
to a generalized
seizure. And this
is due to your
hypersynchrony of neurons
causing pathological
action potential
firing. So for example,
one neuron firing in
a hyper excitatory
aberrant pattern
may cause resting
potential of another
neuron to be closer
to threshold. And
that makes it more
likely to fire an
action potential.
And what you see
here is the spread of
the dye going from one
area, one hemisphere
of the brain to
the other. And this
shows how seizure
activity actually can
spread from one
hemisphere to the other.
Another board's
favorite type of seizure
to talk about are
absence seizures. These
manifest a sudden
blank stare with motor
arrest, usually lasting
less than 15 seconds.
During the seizure,
the patient is usually
unresponsive and
unaware, but they
return immediately
to a baseline level
of function with no
postictal confusion.
Very, very important
to know for your exam
and the boards is the
EEG during absence
seizure shows these
three to five hertz spike
and dome wave formations
that you see here.
This is pathognomonic
for absence seizures,
and you are very
likely to be tested on
this both for your comp
and on your boards.
And another thing I'd
like to mention is
that hyperventilation,
it can actually
be used to trigger
and thus diagnose the
seizure. And I give
you this example here.
A child may present
to the pediatrician
for complaints of
staring off into space
or not paying attention
or focusing in
class or at home when
told to do things.
If you rule out some sort
of issue like autism,
a learning disability,
speech issues,
etc., and a
physician suspects
abson seizure, the
physician can ask
the child to
hyperventilate to see if
this will elicit
an napson seizure.
And then before the
hyperventilation
occurs, you could
hook EEG electrodes up
to the patient's
brain, ask them to
hyperventilate, and you
may see this pattern
here. And then
you can make your
diagnosis, and then
your treatment is with
ethosuxamide, which
is a non-selective
inhibitor of key T
-type calcium channels.
And we'll get into a
little bit more of this
in a later slide,
but the long-term
prognosis, most of these
patients outgrow this.
another board's favorite
febrile seizures
and this affects two
to five percent of
all children mostly
between three months
and six years old and
it is the most common
form of seizure in
children they are
benign in themselves
in the vast majority
but do increase the
risk of other epilepsies
later in life
unfortunately most
febrile seizures are
generalized tonic-clonic
in their presentation
and this poor little
child, you can see
the toes, the fingers,
and the patient's
lips are cyanotic.
And these seizures
can cause brain
injury, especially
in the hippocampus.
For your boards, if
a patient, usually
a child, has a febrile
seizure and you're
in the emergency
room, you can treat
with an antipyretic
such as acetaminophen
and discharge your
patient once vitals
are stable and
follow up with them.
And there is a
strong evidence
for genetic
influence of these
disorders. It's
likely polygenic.
And some genetic
epilepsy syndromes
are known to
start with febrile
seizures, especially
Gervais syndrome,
which we'll get
into a little bit.
So this type of seizure
is a Jacksonian march.
You can imagine that
it's one kind of focal
aware seizure. so
consciousness is not
lost or altered, and
EEG activity is on one
side of one hemisphere
of the brain. But
why it's called a
Jacksonian march is because
seizure activity seems
to march from one
area on the motor strip
or the somatosensory
cortex to the other.
So a patient might
manifest with twitching
or tingling sensation
in a limb or weakness
in a finger. Then
you might have
weakness or tingling in
their big toe or your
corner of your mouth,
and then the seizure
marches over to other
areas as you see here.
So the seizure might
start here at midline,
affecting the knee,
and it might march
all the way over, and
now the patient's jaw
or lips are twitching.
And this represents
the spread of
the abnormal
neuronal activity
to different parts
of the brain.
so eeg is the gold
standard for evaluating
seizures after ct
and m or mri is done
quick point to note is
that ct scans are very
quick usually ordered
before mris in most
emergency settings a
ct scan will be ordered
first in order to rule
out any structural
defects that might be
causing the seizure
while your mri is
more expensive it can
help identify more
subtle lesions, and MRIs
take longer to complete
than CAT scans.
So what we see here
is that you have
different types of
EEGs that you can
use. As you can see
with this arrow here,
as we move through
these different
types of EEGs, you
have more precision
in localizing a
seizure foci. However,
it's more invasive.
So you can plant
surface electrodes
on a patient's
scalp in this
first example here.
You also can plant
electrodes on
the surface of a
patient's brain.
After doing craniotomy
here, it looks like
maybe it's on the
arachnoid layer here.
And you would also
put intracranial
electrodes into
the patient's
brain, as you
can see here.
And what's cool about
the EEG is that you
have different leads.
For example, you have
a frontal lobe lead,
a temporal lobe
lead, an occipital
lobe lead. And this can
be shown on both sides
of the brain, for
example. And what you
see here is this is
normal activity. However,
what you see here
is in the generalized
seizure is activity
in all of these lobes
here, for example,
both in the frontal,
the temporal, and
the occipital, while
a partial seizure
or a focal seizure
might only be
in one lobe, for
example. So this might
just be a frontal
lobe seizure or
a temporal lobe
seizure. for example.
I mentioned pseudo
-seizures before,
psychiatric seizures,
where the patient
might be acting
like they're having
a seizure, maybe
they're twitching,
maybe their muscles
are shaking,
but your EEG is
negative, and the
treatment for this
is psychotherapy.
So what is epilepsy,
right? Epilepsy is a
disease or syndrome in
which chronic, recurrent,
unprovoked seizures
are the salient
feature. It is diagnosed
by an extensive clinical
workup, example
documenting frequency,
duration, behavioral
profile of the seizures.
You can use EEG, MR
imaging, blood work,
past medical history,
age, family history,
etc. And it's also
a disease of the
brain with one, at
least two unprovoked
seizures greater
than 24 hours apart.
It's also one unprovoked
or reflex seizure
in an individual
with a high risk of
subsequent seizures,
example after a TBI,
******, or CNS
infection, or there's
just a diagnosis of
an epilepsy syndrome.
A key point here
that I want to
make is that
seizures and epilepsy
are not just
about neurons.
Mutations can cause
defects in astrocytes,
endothelial cells,
and other channels
associated with these
structures. Think about
your tripartite
synapse, and I'll try to
talk about some good,
have some good images
later in the slides
here to show you.
And just some stats
here. Look at this.
One out of 26 people
in the U.S. will
develop epilepsy at
some point in their
life. This affects
a lot of people. And
that's not to say you
can become a neurologist
and get a fellowship
in epilepsy and
really make an impact
on some of these
patients' lives and
do a lot of good. So
this is an incomplete
list of epilepsy
syndromes, but
the point is that
all of these affect
activities of
daily living and
the quality of life
for the patients
and their family.
There's naturally an
increased mortality
due to a number of
factors, but a key
thing is that all of
these syndromes have
key salient features
that help distinguish
them from one
syndrome from another.
And epilepsy affects
all ages. There's
diverse clinical
syndromes that
separate each syndrome
from the other.
Age of onset matters
a lot, and we'll
go through some of
these differences
between the different
syndromes here.
And also realize
an epilepsy
fellow will be
very familiar with
a lot of these
syndromes here.
so the purpose of
this slide is to
realize that before
we had advanced
genetic analyses
to try to figure
out why someone was
having a seizure
the first thing that
we would do is take
an mri or a ct of
someone having a seizure
and sometimes this the
mri the imaging would
be negative or positive
and if it's positive
you could see a
distinct condition or
disease um that might
be causing the seizure
for example you might
see a neuronal migration
pattern or brain
malformations we might
see this we'll see this
later and this will
be visible on mri
however you might have a
genetic mutation encoding
for some channel,
or a neurotransmitter
related to some channel,
such as acetylcholine,
GABA, or glutamate
receptors, sodium,
potassium, or chloride
ion channels. These
mutations aren't visible
on an MRI, but these
converging arrows are
showing that with
genetic analyses, we can
understand why structural
issues with brain
migration patterns
or issues with ion
channels might be causing
the patient seizure.
And these categories
are becoming
blurred due to
the use of genomic
sequencing in
clinical medicine.
So neochaurical
malformations that can be
associated with
epilepsy. You have least
encephaly. There's no
sulky or gyri. It's
a very smooth brain,
as you can see here.
You have your double
cortex syndrome,
where some neurons
fail to migrate
out of the
ventricular zone here.
You also have
periventricular
nodule heterotopia.
That might be a
cause of epilepsy.
Here you have
hemimegalaencephaly,
where one side
of the brain is
larger than the other.
And you could also have
colossal dysgenesis
or agenesis.
And this is a different
issue compared
to people who get corpus
callosotomies to
treat their seizures,
which we'll get into
in a little bit.
So there are different
structural or
metabolic causes of
seizures in epilepsy.
You could have
malformations of neocortical
development that I
mentioned before a
little bit. You may
have neurocutaneous
syndrome, such as
tuberous sclerosis or
Sturge-Weber syndrome.
Brain tumors can
cause seizures,
infection, head trauma,
vascular malvernations,
fetal anoxia, as well
as strokes, which 11
% of all new cases of
adult onset epilepsy
are caused by strokes.
And now, in the next
slides, we're going
to go over a lot of
different types of
seizures and epilepsy.
For your studying for
your exam, look for
salient and distinguishing
features in the
descriptions of
each disorder, and
this will help you
distinguish one disorder
from another. So, for
example, look at
the genes involved,
patient presentation,
inheritance, age, etc.
Tying these
concepts together
for each diagnosis
is what Dr.
Ramos and myself
will test you on.
So, one of the selected
epilepsy syndromes
we have is Dervais
syndrome, and this is
caused by a de novo
mutation in the scn1a
gene and this encodes
the alpha 1 sodium
channel subunit of
voltage gated sodium
channels in neurons
this gene has been shown
to make nav 1.1
sodium channels and
neurons open more easily
open for longer periods
of time or reopen
faster after closing
and naturally this
leads to more action
potentials being fired
and this is a good
example of an epilepsy
syndrome with a
known gene mutation
and a direct mechanism
related to membrane
physiology of neurons.
And this is an example
of where your MRI
would be negative. And
you might, and back in
the day, if you were
to take an MRI of
this patient's brain,
you would not know what's
causing this person's
seizure. However,
genetic analyses
are helping
bring this to
light of what's
causing this
patient seizure.
To a typical clinical
presentation,
you'll see a
previously normally
developing infant that
has febrile status
epileptics at six
months years old.
Then this patient
will get recurrent
generalized seizures,
often triggered by a fever.
After one year of age,
other seizure types
may appear, including
myoclonic seizures,
abson seizures,
and focal-impaired
awareness and
atonic seizures.
Unfortunately, this
prognosis is poor.
The patient may
suffer intellectual
disability, ataxia,
and spasticity.
So next, we're
moving on to absence
seizures. The gene here
to note is CACNA1H.
And I'll go into the
pathophysiology a
little bit, but I'll
leave it to another
professor to talk about
it. But essentially,
what's something to
think about is you have
thalamocortical relay
cells, which in your
thalamus that go to
your cortex that are
involved in the
regulation of sleep-wake
states, as well as
transmission of sensory
inputs to the
neocortex for conscious
appraisal. When the TCR
neurons are hyperpolarized,
meaning more negative
charge inside
the cell, this causes
a de-inactivation of
type T calcium channels
and the eventual
creation of burst
firing patterns seen in
absence epilepsy as
well as slow-life sleep.
Importantly, this
gates incoming sensory
info to the cortex
and blocks appraisal
of the incoming
sensory information
from your environment.
This explains why
patients who are
having an absent
seizure seem to stare
off into space and
can't respond to
their environment.
And going on,
when these type T
calcium channels
are de-inactivated,
excessive calcium
influx through the type
T calcium channel
essentially causes
this burst mode to
occur, and it locks
these thalamicocortical
neurons in this
sort of three hertz
spike and dome pattern
oscillation that
inhibits the transmission
of external
environmental stimuli.
And we treat this with
ethosuxamide, which
blocks these type
T calcium channels.
So it's important
to realize the
pathophysiology and very
important to realize
the gene involved and
know your spike in
dome, three to five
hertz pattern here.
Another syndrome to
understand is Lennox
-Gutztow syndrome. And
this is a lifelong
developmental epileptic
encephalopathy
that occurs usually
before age of 8 with
a peak onset between
ages 3 and 5. A recent
study estimates
the incidence to be
about 14.5 to 28 per
100,000 individuals.
And it's characterized
by frequent seizures
including a tonic
as well as atypical
absence seizures. This
leads to neuropsychiatric
issues such as
behavioral disorders
as well as intellectual
disabilities.
Lennox-Disco can
arise from genetic
mutations, cortical
malformations, brain
tumors, neurocutaneous
disorders such as
tuberous sclerosis,
as well as hypoxic
ischemic injury. So
the point is that there
is no singular cause,
and in about 40% of
cases, there is no
identifiable cause.
An important EEG
finding to know is an
interrectal 2.5 Hz slow
spike wave discharges
and generalized paroxysmal
fast activity during
sleep. However, we're
less likely to test
you on that EEG pattern,
but what I would
definitely know is the
GABRB3 mutation that
is implicated in this
disorder, and this
makes a beta-3 subunit
of a GABA receptor.
So you can imagine
maybe if a GABA receptor
isn't functioning
correctly, you have less
GABA, or the activity
of GABA is sort of
disrupted, and this may
disrupt your excitation
inhibition balance of
the neurons in your
brain, and this may
lead to your seizure.
The diagnosis
relies on a clinical
presentation,
EEG findings,
brain MRI imaging, as
well as genetic testing.
LGS significantly
impacts patients' quality
of life, and this places
considerable strain
on caregivers and
healthcare systems, and
usually multidisciplinary
care is needed.
Another syndrome, Landau
-Kleffner syndrome,
and this is a rare
age-related epileptic
encephalopathy of
children aged roughly
three to eight
years old with a
previously normal
psychiatric development.
It's important
to realize that
this can be
distinguished from
Lennox-Gastaut
syndrome by language
regression and
seizures in Broca's and
Wernicke's area, and
there is often associated
with a social
cognitive deficit. Like
I mentioned before,
this disorder is
characterized by the
developmental regression
of Broca's and
Wernicke's areas and
EEGs may show seizures
in these areas.
So the patient
may present with
new-onset receptive
and then later
expressive aphasia
in a previously
normally developing
individual.
The seizures, if
present, are mainly
absence or tonic
-clonic episodes, which
may occur more
often during sleep.
Importantly, the gene
involved is this G
-R-I-N-2-A gene, And
this gene makes a
subunit of MDMA
receptors in the neurons.
And naturally,
MDMA receptors have
implications in
learning, memory,
brain development,
etc. et cetera.
Another epilepsy
syndrome is autosomal
dominant partial
epilepsy with auditory
features. So this is
an autosomal dominant
inheritance pattern
epilepsy that is a focal
epilepsy syndrome. And
during the seizure,
a patient will have
auditory symptoms such
as humming, buzzing,
or ringing, and or
a receptive aphasia.
The Wernicke's aphasia
during the seizure
consists of a sudden
onset inability to
understand spoken or
written language without
general confusion.
Less commonly, a
patient will have
visual olfactory or
autonomic symptoms.
The age of onset
is around 10
to 30 years old,
and the clinical
course is
actually benign,
and the seizures are
usually well controlled
after the initiation
of medical therapy.
Something that'll
help you remember
this for your test
is that the seizure
is autosomal dominant
in inheritance.
So naturally, use
family history
to help you make
the diagnosis.
If similar presentations
have occurred
in the patient's
family before,
this will definitely
help you make
the diagnosis, as
rates of de novo
pathogenic mutations
are very low.
So mandatory
criteria to make
the diagnosis
include a normal
MRI, as well as
focal sensory,
auditory seizures,
and or focal cognitive
seizures with receptive
aphasia without
generalized confusion
during the seizure. There
are various genes that
are involved in this,
but the one that I
chose for you to know
is RELN, which actually
encodes for realin.
So next is Sturge-Weber
syndrome, and this
is a nice example of a
disorder with a known
gene, a robust clinical
physical and clinical
presentation and a
classic MRI signature.
So this is a congenital
non-hereditary
anomaly of neural crest
cell derivatives, and
the pathogenesis involves
somatic mosaicism
of an activating
mutation in one copy of
the GNAQ gene. The
GNAQ gene is vital for
blood vessel development.
Remember, somatic
mosaicism involves
genetic DNA mutations
or alterations in copy
number of cellular
genomes that occur post
-fotolarization that
create two distinct
populations of cells.
And what we see here
is that it involves
specific regions of
the brain. You see this
unilateral picture here
of where you see an
ipsilateral leptomeningeal
angioma with
calcifications. And you
also see a port wine stain
here involved in the
V1 or V2 distribution.
And this also
increased the risk
of neuroocular
issues as well.
So you may have
intellectual
disability or early
onset glaucoma.
So another syndrome
that actually doesn't
involve neurons directly,
it actually involves
astrocytes, is the
GLUT1 deficiency
syndrome. So it's
important to realize that
astrocytes get glucose
from cerebral arteries.
Astrocytes then
transform glucose to
lactate to help shuttle
lactate to neurons
for ATP production.
However, what we see here
in this diagram here
is that you have this
GLUT1 transporter in
the endothelial cell.
However, if there's
a mutation in this
GLUT1, it's hard to
transport glucose from
the blood vessel, from
the endothelial cell
into the astrocyte,
and if that doesn't
happen, how can the
astrocyte then send glucose
or lactate to the
nerve cell for fuel?
So this is an issue
where you have
an issue that's
actually not occurring
in a neuron, rather
an astrocyte,
or I'm sorry, an
endothelial cell.
And something to
think about is after
ruling out infectious
age through
meningitis, and the
patient has had a seizure,
and you see low
glucose in the CSF,
think about this
disorder as a potential
cause, as
hypoglycorrhokia, or low
concentration of
glucose in the CSF, is a
very defining feature
of this syndrome.
Symptoms may include
developmental
delay, intellectual
disability, movement
problems, and
frequent seizures.
Another syndrome is
EAST syndrome. EAST
syndrome involves a
mutation in the KCNJ10
gene, and this presents
with epilepsy, ataxia,
and sensoriminal
deference, as well as
kidney tubulopathy.
And what we see here is
that this gene encodes
for an ATP-sensitive
potassium channel
that's only found in
astrocytes and this
gene encodes for a
channel for astrocytes to
clear out extracellular
potassium going
back to membrane
physiology remember
that too much potassium
in the extracellular
space results in
depolarization of
neurons as this actually
makes the threshold
for firing it raises it
raises resting membrane
potential of the
neuron closer to
threshold. And remember the
massive role of potassium
leak channels in
maintaining resting
membrane potential.
And we have the
tripartite synapse
here, where we see
the gene encoding
the KIR 4.1 channel
that's essentially
involved in
shuttling potassium
out of the synapse
into the astrocyte.
Now, the next syndrome
we're going to
talk about is glutamine
deficiency syndrome.
And this mutation
of the one gene
that includes glutamine
synthase that is
preferentially
expressed in astrocytes.
So the onset of the
seizures will occur in
the first few days of
life or weeks of life.
Affected infants will
show severely impaired
psychomotor development
with hypotonia,
spasticity, lack of
speech, poor visual
fixation, as well as
feeding difficulties that
may necessitate a feeding
tube. Now, what we
see here is that the
GLU1 gene includes
glutamine synthetase
here that's involved in
the conversion of
glutamine to glutamine. And
naturally, if this gene
and this enzyme are
deficient, you're
going to have a buildup
of reactants and one
of those reactants is
actually ammonia and
it's possible that the
increased ammonia may
contribute to developmental
issues and naturally
from this your
GABA and glutamate
balance can be disrupted
and it's also important
to realize that
glutamine is hit with
this enzyme glutaminase
and it converts,
glutamine gets converted
back to glutamate
here, and glutamate is
actually then hit
with another enzyme,
glutamate decarboxylase,
and that turns
glutamate to GABA, and
that occurs in neurons.
Another syndrome is
developmental and
epileptic encephalopathy
41, DEE 41, and this
occurs because of a
mutation of the EAA2
excitatory amino
acid transporter. And
the issue here, as
you see, is that there
is too much glutamine
in the extracellular
space. And glutamine,
as we know, is an
excitatory
neurotransmitter. And this
causes depolarization
of neurons leading to
hyperexcitability
and the propagation
of aberrant
action potentials.
So we see the EAA2
gene on what probably
is an astrocyte here
that's responsible
for shuttling glutamate
that's released
from the presynaptic
neuron back into the
glia out of the synapse
so that glutamate
can't bind to its
receptor and cause the
polarization of the
postsynaptic neuron.
It's characterized by
the onset of seizures
in the first days or
weeks of life. affected
infants may show
severely impaired
psychomotor activity with
hypotonia, spasticity,
or a lack of speech or
poor visual fixation.
So naturally, there are
very similar presenting
manifestations
here between these
two types of
syndromes, but the
most important thing
I would know is
your gene. If you
know the gene,
you will be
able to get the
answer it right
on the test.
Next, a board's favorite,
tubular sclerosis.
This is a neurocutaneous
disorder with
autosomal dominant
inheritance pattern,
and the genes were
identified in the
You have two genes
here, TCS1 and TSC2.
So what we see here
is TCS1 is encoding
hermitin, while TSC2
is encoding tuberin.
Both of these
things actually down
-regulate mTOR, and
mTOR is the mammalian
target of rapamycin.
that's involved in
cell growth, autophagy,
and metabolism.
So you can imagine
that if cell growth
is not downregulated,
you will have
essentially hermitomas
in different
areas of your body.
So for example,
a shade green patch is
just a hyperproliferation
of some type of
skin cells here.
Brain hermitomas
here also can occur.
You could also get
an ash leaf spot,
which is a piece of
area of hypopigmented
skin, as well as a
facial angiofibroma.
And it's important to
realize a harmatoma
is a proliferation
of tissue that's in
the area affected. So
if I have a harmatoma
in my brain, for
example, it will be
composed of neurons
or glia, for example.
And your mnemonic,
the clinical
mnemonic, is ash
leaf. So you have
ash leaf spots,
shea green patches,
heart rhabdomyosychomas,
lung hematomas, and
brain hematomas that
will cause your
epilepsy. And these
seizures are very
difficult to control.
You could also have
angiomyolipomas in the
kidney as well as
facial angiofibromus.
you could also have a
hypothalamic hermitoma
and seizures from that
and what we see here
is the hypothalamus
is big because there
is a abnormal proliferation
of the cells there
and like I said before
hermitoma is just
an abnormal proliferation
of the tissue type
in the area so this
cell this mass here is
just made of neurons
and glia. And very
important to note, this
hypothalamic hormatoma
can cause gelastic or
dicrastic seizures. And
also important to
realize that a child may
experience early puberty
and irritability,
as well as aggression
between seizures due to
********* GNRH or
gonadotropin-releasing
hormone elevations and
pulsations, which you'll
learn about into your
endocrine section.
And so, well, think
about this. This
could also help you
make your diagnosis.
Maybe we give
you that in the
question, for
example, mention
that in the stem
of it, right?
And the treatment of this
includes surgical
resection.
Next, medial temporal
lobe epilepsy.
30% of these are
inretractable, and
pharmacological
treatment is minimal.
and temporal lobe
epilepsy accounts for
about 70% of
intractable epilepsies.
MTLE usually manifests
as generalized
toniclonic seizures
and they most
commonly start in
the hippocampus.
And medial temporal
lobe sclerosis, what
you see here is you
have scarring and a
loss of volume and
atrophy of the medial
temporal lobe structures,
most notably of
the hippocampus. What
we see here is that
you have sclerosis in
this hippocampus, and
you could see some
atrophy of some of
these hippocampal cells
here in the image.
And the pathophysiology
underlying MTS is
medial temporal lobe
sclerosis is unknown.
another very rare
clinical syndrome is
rasmussen syndrome
named after a canadian
neurosurgeon and it's a
rare pediatric encephalitis
that affects one
hemisphere of this brain
this very pathognomonic
mri showing how
one half of the brain
is inflamed uh what you
see here is It's a T-cell
-dominated encephalitis
with activated
microglial cells, and
it creates a reactive
astrogliosis that is
apparent on histiopathological
examination.
It's very rare. You
have a 1.8 to 2.4
out of every 10 million
people affected,
and so it's very
uncommon, and it
usually presents in
normally developing
pediatric boys age
6 to 8 most common.
um going back to this
activation of microglial
cells and reactive
astrogliosis what's
causing this microglial
activation and
subsequent astrogliosis
is unknown no antigen
that cns immune
cells attack has been
identified it's
characterized by recurrent
seizures delayed
developmental milestones
as well as progressive
cognitive decline and
this can be acquired
throughout through
a medical history
neuroimaging will show
chronic inflammatory
changes and progressive
hemispheric atrophy.
In short, we really
don't know what causes
this disease, and
the treatment involves
a hemisphere rectomy
of the affected brain
lobe or hemisphere.
A disorder that's
actually coming
a little bit more
to light, and we
figured out a little
bit more about
it recently, is
NDMA encephalitis.
So this is actually
one of the most common
encephalitis. It
occurs in one out
of every 1.5 million
people per year.
And pathognomonic disorder
are IgG antibodies
forming against
the NR1 subunit of
the NDMA receptors of
the central nervous
system. This is a
hallmark of the disease.
I would know this
fact for your test.
Unlike Rasmussen
syndrome, we actually have
an idea about what
antibody is attacking
antigen, and these
antibodies are identifiable
in the serum or the
CSF. Plasma exchange
helps reduce the
amount of anti-MDMA
receptor antibodies
in the serum, and this
disorder seems to be
triggered by viruses such
as ****** simplex or
ovarian teratomas,
which is a type of tumor
you'll learn about.
And with that being
said, transvaginal
ultrasonography is
a very crucial test
for young women presenting
with the illness
due to high incidence
of underlying
ovarian teratomas with
NEMA encephalitis.
As with most autoimmune
disorders, women
aged 25 to 35 are most
commonly affected.
Here are some of these
five clinical stages.
You could have a
prodrome phase that
might mimic a viral
infection. There's a
psychotic phase where you
might have psychiatric
symptoms, including
visual or auditory
hallucinations, even
acute schizoaffective
episodes, depression,
mania, apathy, etc.
There's the next,
the unresponsive
phase where the patient
might be mute with
decreased motor
activity or catatonia.
After that,
you evolve to a
hyperkinetic phase with
lip and tongue smacking
as well as autonomic
instability.
And then five is a
recovery of language and
behavioral symptoms
that occur at the end.
And I like this
syndrome because it
really makes you think
that maybe psychiatric
conditions and
neurological conditions
aren't that different
because you're
having a neurological
disorder causing
psychiatric symptoms.
And it's a very
interesting disorder
where it's sort of
affecting a person
from both a neurologic
as well as a
psychiatric standpoint.
something that actually
interests me
very, very much.
So treatments,
right? We talked
a lot about some
of these disorders.
What can we
do about them?
The goal of the therapy
is seizure freedom
or to at least reduce
seizure frequency,
have seizures that don't
affect consciousness
or at least take a
generalized seizure
down to a focal
seizure, for example.
Dr. Goldstein
will teach you a
lot about the
pharmacology here.
Some types of seizures
and epilepsy can
be treated with surgery,
as well as brain
stimulation, as
well as vagal nerve
stimulators, as
shown here, that can
essentially increase
parasympathetic tone.
Interestingly enough,
a ketogenic diet might
actually help seizures.
The mechanism is
entirely understood.
It may affect cellular
metabolism enough to
increase the seizure
threshold. Usually a diet
minimal in carbohydrates.
This can stimulate
lipolysis of ketones
from the liver, which
may be affecting
resting membrane potential
and overall proclivity
of neurons to fire
action potentials.
There's also roles for
yoga, acupuncture, etc.
So what we see here is
that we could actually,
if someone has
intractable epilepsy in
the temporal lobe, you
could actually stick
an electrode in the
patient's brain and
sort of monitor electrical
activity in that
area of the brain.
It's kind of like a
pacemaker for cardiac
arrhythmia, where you
have electrodes essentially
hooked up to the
focal area that the
seizure is occurring.
This is in the
hippocampus
bilaterally, and
this one's in the
temporal lobe, as
you can see here.
And the stimulation
and the implantation
of these devices
can be effective
in some patients,
and it can be
combined with other
therapy modalities.
Very cool here. A
neurosurgeon can
implant a device
here for deep brain
stimulation for
intractable epilepsy.
And what we see here
is that you have
different things,
whether it's you
can stick something
in the let's
look at the anatomy
here where you have
the head of the
caudate, putamen.
Here's part of your
thalamus, two little
spots here for your
deep brain stimulation
that could affect
seizure activity.
And like before, it's
like a pacemaker,
similar to a cardiac
arrhythmia, where you
implant an electrical
device that sort of
recognizes aberrant
electrical activity in the
foci it's in, and
then actually goes and
attenuates some of the
activity of the area.
And this is effective
in some patients
with a 50% reduction
in seizures
after five to six
years, and it could
also be combined with
other modalities.
to treat medial temporal
lobe epilepsy you
could also use a
surgical resection and
really the goal is to
destroy the abnormal
circuits that initiate
the generalized seizures
as well as to not
destroy the circuits
important for our
functions of daily living
and think about your
temporal lobe maybe
it's involved in
memory hearing so you
don't want to destroy
the pathways that are
actually vital for a
patient's functioning.
Naturally, this is a
last resort option here.
Now, you could even
use a hemispirectomy.
Patients with unilateral
epilepsy that is
poorly controlled with
medications are candidates
for this type of
surgery. You can imagine
how invasive this
is, and you could see
how this is definitely
a last resort option
here. And given how
invasive this is? Would
you expect this to
be done in adults or
peds more? And what
would account for this
difference? This is
just a thought question,
but this would be
more likely to be done
in pediatrics because
pediatric brains,
child's brains, there's
more synaptic pruning.
Neuroplasticity is
heightened during this
time. And if you remove
a part of a patient's
brain that might be
involved in maybe some
type of cognition, for
example, another area
of the patient's brain
in this neuroplastic
state may accommodate
that lost function
of the area of the
brain that was resected.
While in an
adult brain, this
is much less
likely to happen.
This, what we see
here, is actually a
corpus callosotomy in
an attempt to treat
generalized seizures.
And why would we cut
the corpus callosomized?
Because it's a
white matter tract
that's connecting both
hemispheres of the
brain. But what's
interesting here is that
we leave the splenium
intact because the
splenium seems to
be important for sort
of these emotional
sort of emotions
that a person might
feel. So if you leave
the splenium intact,
you could
essentially stop the
seizure from
progressing while
also maintaining
some function. I
also want to mention
that this is different
than a person who
might just have a
seizure due to a
malformed corpus callosum.
Here you actually
remove the corpus
callosum to help try
to treat the seizure.
These are some of
your conclusions to
think about. We talked
about a lot today,
different types
of seizures and
epilepsy, the
pathophysiology behind it,
as well as some
potential treatments.
I tried to stress to
you guys how to look
at some of these
syndromes, what to look at,
presentation, age
of presentation,
how the patient
presents, inheritance,
genes involved. And if
you keep these things
straight, you will
increase your chances
of getting the questions
right on the test.
and I have some questions
here for you that
you can go over on
your own um I have
four of them I'm not
going to go through
them uh this that'll
take too long and uh
I'm not going to go
through it now I don't
want to give the
answers away but um if
you guys have any
questions related to these
questions please let
Dr. Ramos and I know
and any feedback is
welcomed I appreciate
your time Have a
lovely day. Thank you